hello fellow hunters this is a quick
guide on how to get to the new area in
the blood-borne expansion called the
hunters nightmare in order to gain
access to the new content and the new
area you're gonna have to do a few
things first the first thing you're
gonna need to do is defeat vicar Amelia
after defeating her make sure to trigger
the event at the altar behind her once
you've done that make your way back to
the hunter stream and you'll have access
to getting a gift from the messengers
called the eye of a blood-drunk hunter
the messengers you're looking for will
be right next to the doll if you happen
to have a save where you've already
killed Amelia then all you need to do is
head to the hunters dream and grab the
gift from the messengers once you
receive the item make your way to the
cathedral ward take the first left that
you can and you'll end up in this
courtyard when you're in the courtyard
locate this dead body and you'll then be
grabbed by one of those huge alien
spider looking things once it grabs you
you'll be teleported away to the hunters
nightmare welcome to the new area and
have fun exploring the new content new
enemies and new weapons stay tuned to
games.com for continuing coverage of
blood-borne the old hunters
you